what number sets does the number three
point four zero two eight repeating
belong doing before even answering the
question let's just think about what
this represents and especially what this
line on top means so this line on top
means the two eight just keep repeating
forever so I could express this number
as 3.40 to eight for the two eight just
keep repeating just keep repeating on
and on and on forever I could just keep
writing them forever and ever and
obviously it's just easier to write this
line over the to eight to say that it
repeats forever now let's think about
what number sets it belongs to
well the broadest number said we've
dealt with so far is the real numbers
and this definitely belongs to the real
numbers the real numbers is essentially
the entire number line that we're used
to using and 3.40 to eight repeating
sits someplace over here if this is
negative one this is zero one two three
four 3.40 to eight is a little bit more
than three point four a little bit less
than three point four one it would sit
right over there so it's definitely sits
on the number line it's a real number so
it definitely is real it definitely is a
real number but the not so obvious
question is whether it is a rational
number remember a rational number is one
that can be expressed as a rational
expression or as a fraction if I were to
tell you if I were to tell you that P is
rational P is rational that means that P
can be expressed as the ratio of two
integers that means that means that P
that means that P can be expressed as
the ratio of two integers M over N so
the question is can i express this as
the ratio of two integers or another way
to think of it can i express this as a
fraction and to do that let's actually
express it as a fraction so let's say
that let's define X as being equal to
this number so X X is equal to three
point four o28 repeating now let's think
about what 10,000 X is and the only
reason I want 10,000
because I want to move the decimal point
all the way to the right over here so
10,000 X 10,000 X what is that going to
be equal to well every time you multiply
by a power of 10 you shift the decimal
one to the right 10,000 is 10 to the
fourth power so it's like shifting the
decimal over to the right four spaces
one two three four so it'll be 34,000
twenty-eight but these two eights just
keep repeating so that you'll have
you'll still have the two eights go on
and on and on and on own after that they
just all got shifted to the left of the
decimal point by five spaces you could
view it that way that makes sense it's a
little over
it's nearly three and a half if you
multiply it by 10,000 you get almost
35,000 so that's 10,000 X now let's also
think about 100x and my whole exercise
here is I want to get two numbers that
when I subtract them and they're in
terms of X the repeating part disappears
and then we can just treat them as
traditional numbers so let's think about
what 100x is 100x
that moves this decimal point remember
the decimal point was here originally it
moves it over to the right two spaces so
100x would be 300 let me write it like
this it would be 340 point two eight
repeating to eight repeating we could
have put the two eight repeating here
but it wouldn't have made as much sense
you always want to write it after the
decimal point so we have to write to
eight again to show that it's repeating
now something interesting is going on
these two numbers they're just multiples
of X and if I subtract the bottom one
from the top one what's going to happen
well the repeating part is going to
disappear so let's do that let's do that
on both sides of this equation let's do
it so on the left-hand side of this
equation 10,000 X minus 100 X is going
to be nine thousand nine hundred X and
on the right hand side let's see that
the decimal part will cancel out and we
just have to figure out what thirty four
thousand 28 minus 340 is so let's just
figure this out eight is larger than
zero so we won't have to do any
regrouping there two is less than four
so we will have to do some regrouping
but we can't borrow yet because we've
had a zero over there so the Z and zero
is less than three so we have to do some
grouping there some borrowing so let's
borrow from the four first so if we
borrow from the four this becomes a
three and then this becomes a ten and
then the two can now borrow from the ten
this becomes a nine and this becomes a
twelve and now we can do the subtraction
eight minus 0 is 8 12 minus 4 is 8 9
minus 3 is 6 3 minus nothing is 3 3
minus nothing is 3 so 900 9900 X is
equal to 33,000 688 we just subtracted
340 from this up here so we get 33,000
688 now if we want to solve for X we
just divide both sides by 9900 we just
divide both sides by 9900 divide the
left by 9900 divide the right by 9900
and then what are we left with we're
left with X is equal to 33,000 688 over
9900 now what's the big deal about this
well X was this number X was this number
that we started off with this number
that just kept on repeating and by doing
a little bit of algebraic manipulation
and subtracting one multiple of it from
another were able to express that same
exact X as a fraction now this isn't in
simplest terms these probabilities have
the I mean they're both definitely
divisible by two and it looks like by 4
so you could put this in lowest common
form but we don't care about that
all we care about is the fact that we
were able to represent X we were able to
represent this number as a fraction as
the ratio of two integers so the number
is also rational it is also rational and
this technique we did it doesn't it
doesn't only apply to this number
anytime you have a number that has
repeating digits you could do this so in
general repeating digits are rational
the ones that are irrational are the
ones that never ever ever repeat like pi
anyway and so the other things I think
it's pretty obvious this isn't an
integer the integers are the whole
numbers that we're dealing with so this
is some
is in between the integers it's not a
natural number or a whole number which
depending on the context review two
subsets or of integers so Stephenie none
of those so it is real and it is
rational that's all we can say about it